grâce à bernardo perotto orléans devient
à la fin du xviie siècle un des
principaux centres du fer cet italien
qui va franciser son nom en bernard
perron pas inventé de nombreuses
techniques complètement révolutionnaire
verre coloré vers blancs imitant de la
porcelaine et surtout grande invention
avec un retentissement économique que le
sel des grandes plaques de verre coulé
sur table de métal qui permettront de
faire des grandes vitres contrairement
aux petits carreaux qui étaient réalisés
jusqu'à présent
c'est cette technique qui va utiliser
pour des médaillons du roi de sa famille
comme celui ci où il va laisser en creux
le visage du roi écoulé le vert par
dessus
il ment succès le roi puis qu'on filme m
un privilège qui lui permet de s'imposer
dans le panorama national
ça ne lui attire pas que les sympathies
et en dépit de son soutien royal
la manufacture de saint gobain jalouse
cette belle invention des grandes
plaques de verre qui permettront de
faire des glaces de faire des grandes
vitres va lui voler son procédé le faire
faire saisir tout son atelier et le
mettre sur la paille pour finalement
devenir elle-même lac leman de
manufacture du xviiie siècle
[Musique]